milagro encaramanmaras una mujer es una
de las más recientes supervivientes de
la destrucción que dejó el terremoto en
Turquía Se desconoce su edad pero lo que
se sabe según medios locales es que
otras 250 personas murieron en el mismo
edificio de cuyas ruinas ella fue
rescatada
karamán Mara hace una provincia del
sureste de Turquía fue este jueves un
lugar en el que la esperanza se abrió
camino en medio del dolor esta joven de
17 años fue rescatada con vida después
de pasar 248 horas bajo los escombros su
nombre aleina su apellido olmes que se
traduce aquella que no muere no tiene
fracturas de hueso importantes sus
funciones cerebrales están bien la zona
de su pecho todos sus órganos están en
buenas condiciones
en la provincia de hatay El Milagro vino
de la mano del rescate de ese
adolescente Turquía aún cuenta con unos
8.000 rescatistas y miembros de personal
de asistencia sobre el terreno pero ya
unos 4.000 se han marchado en Siria
Naciones Unidas estima que los
fallecidos son 6000 aquí pese a la
magnitud de la tragedia las zonas bajo
control del gobierno y las zonas
Rebeldes aún no intercambian ayuda
humanitaria el presidente sirio va a
llegar al azar no se olvida del
conflicto final
vale la pena destacar que estos retos no
solamente están relacionados con el
terremoto son el resultado de años de
una guerra destructiva y terrorismo de
la asedio y sus consecuencias y los
recientes terremotos tanto en Turquía
como en Siria ya hay zonas afectadas por
el seísmo en donde las autoridades
ordenaron la suspensión de las labores
de rescate